les gens se fait 40 ans qu'il me voit et
qui m'écoutent
enfin j'espère alors certes de moi force
ce que les gens savent pas c'est que mon
vrai nom c'est boc
autoliv a marre j'aurais peut-être dû
réfléchir plus j'ai pris trop vite mon
pseudonyme sur les grandes un truc plus
douchy quoi imaginer égal maintenant un
jeune chanteur avec une chanson qui a un
grand potentiel
la chanson s'appelle du côté de chipman
et les chanteurs s'appelle anna kuna
torpédo inra à toi ça claque à j'ai
chanté des centaines de chansons j'ai
fait des dizaines de disques j'ai fait
des millions de kilomètres j'ai fait des
milliers des spectacles et pourtant on
me pose toujours la même question alors
dave la france veut savoir est ce que
vous aimez les dames question qui saoule
et la mimolette 1
vous allez la bible est la même depuis
20 ans plein le cul il ya un autre donc
non par tout temps aussi ce que se
présenter leur vision avec moi que je
faisais ce que les gens savent moins
c'est que je les fais moi leur vision et
j'ai fini troisième sur le podium et
sébastien terrier
il a fini combien lui convient dix
neuvièmes donc sébastien tellier
mais aujourd'hui j'ai fait du cinéma bon
quand on est venu me chercher je croyais
que c'était pour déconner pas si souvent
me demande sur les manèges la piste
michael douglas hollywood studios et
cette audience
elle est bonne voyez et quand je la
remets au lever et aller lui dit t'es
pas morte un nom mec
j'adhère je ne me brand plupart c'est
trop fatiguant personnes par quoi